quién eres tú no sé si ustedes han visto
una película que se llama locos de ira
bueno no se preocupen es una película
bastante gracias enloquecida en dónde
en donde hay una terapia de grupo y
entonces jack nicholson que son uno de
mis actores favoritos es el terapeuta
entonces estaba yo pensando qué
sucedería si yo fuera la paciente de la
terapia de grupo de jacques fuera el
terapeuta entonces me podría preguntar y
bien al inah dinos quién eres
bueno eso es muy fácil de contestar yo
soy alina barón soy la directora de la
compañía de teatro de la universidad
anáhuac del sur y yo me estoy
preguntando quién eres no dónde trabajas
claro por supuesto yo en realidad bueno
yo soy una persona que le gusta salir a
caminar al bosque le gusta comer
palomitas me gusta hacer teatro no no no
no no te pregunte cuáles son tus hobbies
te pregunté quién
que soy
y no podrías darme alguna pista
ajá quieres que yo te diga quién eres tú
por supuesto que no claro que no yo
bueno verás yo soy
una persona tranquila pacífica a veces
un poco nerviosa pero no no te pregunte
las características de tu personalidad
te pregunte quién eres
disculpe el exabrupto pero es que a
veces hay cosas que son un poco
complicados y cuando llego a esta
pregunta quién eres tú pues la verdad si
me confundo porque si yo creo que soy
quien digo que soy a la hora de la hora
no soy eso según jack nicholson entonces
francamente cristiano sé quién soy
sin embargo
vamos a darle otra
cuando me empieza a dar cuenta que yo
voy a estar conmigo durante toda mi vida
entonces puede que sí la verdad es que
si sepa un poco sobre mí
mis papás mis compañeros mis amigos mis
maestros mi pareja todas esas personas
que están conmigo van a estar cerca por
un tiempo sin embargo la que va a estar
conmigo misma toda la vida
soy yo entonces de ahí que yo creo que
si me conviene llevarme de pelos conmigo
misma porque yo me voy a acompañar de
principio a fin
entonces pensándolo bien creo que si hay
cosas que sé de mí aunque a veces pues
por supuesto puede que me confunda
entonces puedo pensar que soy mi nombre
o puedo pensar que soy mi apellido o
puedo pensar que soy la ropa que traigo
o el coche que tengo allá afuera o la
escuela donde vengo puedo pensar que soy
muchas cosas pero en realidad yo no soy
eso yo soy otra cosa que es lo que me
conforma como ser humano
entonces vuelvo a pensar
soy
sí sé algunas cosas de mí y entonces ahí
cuando me doy cuenta que sé algunas
cosas de mí puedo tener este otro
diálogo que sería muy chistoso que es lo
que más se te antoja ahorita la verdad
pues ahorita con la lluvia pero mejor un
capuchino pero solo un capuchino frappé
creo que es demasiado no crees
si sabes que el capuchino no se engorda
no
ay sí pero qué importancia frío y
ahorita con la lluvia se me antoja
también no te hagas vamos por el
capuchino y luego hacemos la caminadora
que dices
pero si te acuerdas que el capuchino no
sube el colesterol verdad
bueno sí pero ya no te pongas tan mal no
seas negativa vamos por el cappuccino
entonces este diálogo que parece
simplista es el diálogo que yo tengo
conmigo mismo todo el tiempo yo esto que
hago así de esa manera que acabo de
ilustrar hacemos nuestras elecciones así
hablo con mi misma así me expreso y así
decido y así elijo
entonces lo que parece tan sencillo ya
no lo es y hay cosas que se ponen más
divertidas cuando soy más joven y cuando
mi tía martha llega con la pregunta
estelarísima qué es lo que vas a hacer
cuando seas grande niña y entonces yo
pienso que
bueno primero voy a hablar del otro hay
personas que dan respuestas de inmediato
y entonces dicen bueno pues yo voy a
hacer ingeniero químico otras dicen
bueno pues yo voy a hacer doctor otras
dicen yo voy a ser escritora
yo voy a hacer actriz
todas esas personas que hablan con esa
facilidad y desde que nacen saben lo que
van a estudiar tienen mi más absoluto
respeto y para mí se llaman iluminados
son los iluminados pero aquí la mayoría
que somos unas perfectas personas
normales entonces podemos pensar que
bueno aquí vamos a hacer un ejercicio
quien de los que están aquí puede
levantar la mano y todavía no sabe qué
carrera va a estudiar
ok
y peor aún
pero de los que ya estamos aquí que
trabajamos quien estudió algo y trabaja
en otra cosa
ahora estamos puestos esto solamente no
es un juicio al contrario solamente es
para demostrar que las personas
cambiamos lo único que no cambia es el
cambio todos cambiamos porque porque
ayer me gustaba el brócoli hoy no me
gusta porque ayer me gustaban las
películas chistosas y hoy me gustan las
películas románticas porque hay otras
cosas más profundas como por ejemplo los
desengaños amorosos antes era algo muy
importante para mí yo ya no me acuerdo
entonces vamos cambiando en el tiempo y
gracias a ese cambio pues es que nos
vamos desarrollando afortunadamente no
cuando a veces escucho algunos diálogos
entre las personas muy mayores que dicen
entonces van persie
se refieren sin duda alguna al panteón
y esto no es muy halagador y no me
quiero poner tétrica - en una tarde
lluviosa como hoy sin embargo reconozco
que tienen un punto y el punto es que el
efecto nosotros nacemos para morir mal
plan pero así es ahora el chiste es que
si podemos hacer la diferencia en el
trayecto porque desde que nazca crezco
me reproduzco y muero ahí es donde yo
puedo hacer la diferencia como eligiendo
como conociendo me puedo empezar a
conocerme a mí mismo y puedo saber a
dónde quiero ir y no me refiero a un
lugar me refiero a un destino cuál es
qué es lo que yo quiero construir si yo
sé qué es lo que quiero ser entonces voy
a saber qué es lo que quiero hacer
porque independientemente de qué es lo
que quiere hacer me niego a vivir la
vida de una autómata esto es me niego a
levantarme todos los días a la misma
hora a comer todos los días el mismo
rible desayuno irme por el mismo rible
camino al mismo horrible trabajo hacer
lo mismo de siempre a comer con los
mismos compañeros y regresar por el
mismo camino a ver el mismo programa a
dormir y a vivir el sueño de todas las
noches horrible igual que siempre me
niego y no se los deseo ustedes tampoco
la vida de un robot no es para las
personas que tenemos algo más adentro
que no somos robots
entonces una vez que yo sé y que empiezo
a descubrir mi pasión en la vida todo lo
demás va a ser regalado porque entonces
voy a empezar a caminar hacia allá y
entonces mis sueños y mis metas estarán
acompañados de mis pasos hacia ese
destino que yo decido como por ejemplo
el este niño ir bien que acaba de meter
el gol a alemania donde todos estábamos
súper felices porque ya habíamos ganado
alemania y cuando estamos viendo aquel
partido y empieza y va ahí entonces
y no me puedo quedar con el grito porque
lo tengo que gritar porque no puedo eso
señoras y señores se llama pasión y
cuando yo encuentro mi pasión como el
encuentra la suya entonces todo lo demás
se vuelve mágico porque la tarea porque
el trabajo porque las cosas que tengo
que hacer para lograr aquello son la
pura diversión es un reto a mi
inteligencia que a mí me gusta hacer
porque voy hacia allá y todo eso es
divertido entonces pues no hay tragedia
por supuesto aquí está el niño
este es el chiste empezamos a descubrir
nuestra pasión
es lo que les digo todo se vuelve
divertido y entonces por ellos y yo
descubro mi pasión pues me vuelvo
naturalmente una persona feliz
para terminar les diré que william
shakespeare el gran escritor escribió
aquella obra que se llamaba hamlet y
todos conocemos el monólogo de hamlet
donde sable dice ser o no ser
he ahí el dilema
si hamlet hubiera sabido quién era
no hubiera tenido que matar a todos los
demás personajes y luego suicidarse por
dios era el príncipe de dinamarca no
vaya a destino no puedo evitarlo soy
maestra entonces la tarea
quién eres
y qué harás con el resto de tu vida
gracias
[Aplausos]